we have been socialists in Sweden and we
have been successful but never at the
same time we had that period in the
1970s and 1980s when Sweden was doubling
the size of public consumption raising
taxes regulating everything today if
Bernie Sanders want to imitate Sweden he
would have to reform Social Security
partially privatize it he would have to
open up and privatize some much of
product markets deregulate abolish
occupational licensing reduce many taxes
reduce corporate taxes from the U.S
level the bullish property taxes and
inheritance taxes and stuff like that
implementing National School voucher
systems so private schools get the same
funding as as public ones so Sweden
today is not what he remembers from the
1970s it's it's a much better and and
Freer place than it was back then